let's play
another challenge
playing
gerhard gaffar
10 minutes rapid chess
is my opponent here opponents here okay
play another uh alekhine
holding off on a stafford
question from get profit
what's the worst first move for white
um according to
i think according to the engine or most
like strong engines
it's
g4 at least according to sese
it's a norwegian super computer
okay so next game i'll play a random
challenge so completely random viewer so
if you're a sub or even not a sub
[Music]
it's all fair game
currently have about 60 pending
challenges
okay i kind of want to go insane here
i'm going to play
what probably shouldn't be a good move
but it looks kind of fun
get some g5 emotes
the point is to just open the g file
and try and punish white
[Music]
so white's not taking it
well i guess now i have to justify g5
with the rook on g8
go for g4
and white's just trying to play like
clean
normal chests
did you see fabiano win connect four
yesterday
ooh
trying to remember the game
it was real slimo
[Music]
i'm trying to remember the pawn
structure i know he had some cool like
pawn storm thing
also i think i'm winning material now
it's like a weird
unexpected opening trap
yeah very unfortunate for whites because
i i was really the one disobeying
opening principles
but that's why he was getting punished
yeah i did kind of glaze over the
faviano game
there's a nice uh
rosalina win against sweets
i also finished with a a triple fork
speaking of triple
oh i'm not winning more material
oh that was very clever knight c3
knight c3 saves everything
except the bishop that was already taken
um
i have to be careful too because i might
be losing a queen
i think i'll play this move
there is a funny line where i lose my
queen but i get
both knights for
it i already won the bishop so it's
possible we'll get like a
situation where i have three minors for
the queen
yeah like here maybe takes
this is also an option but after it
takes
takes takes its takes
over kch8
let's do that
so i'll actually have
a bishop
knight and rook
for the queen
and pawn
so kind of a cool material imbalance
in black definitely has enough material
for the the queen
it's just a matter of developing
develop and defend
maybe f5 coming soon
yeah these sort of positions like you
still have to coordinate your pieces but
should be more pleasant for black
this is such a weird game so far like
started as an alkyne
in this g5 move
won material
almost kind of got my queen trapped i
kind of did because if here there's this
and now
i have to show what i have for the queen
95 is very confrontational
i think i'll just play e6
even though it blocks in the bishop
just trying to force white to
simplify a bit
my tea is is dwindling
pretty low on t
i made a a pretty large pot of tea as
well before the stream
so i think i'm set
there's a question about f5
yeah f5 was another
option which
maybe i could have looked into a bit
closer
i'm just more excited about
the prospect of trading and then having
a
half open file for the rook
also realizing there's a cool idea rook
h4
is to rook lift
wow
so white wants to play this take away my
knight and then win the bishop
i mean the first thing that comes to
mind is
can i get away with taking the pawn
[Music]
uh let's do it
thank you chern nobel prize subbing with
prime
now
[Music]
oh there's a really funny line
it's really funny
oh no my bishop
[Music]
and when white takes the bishop it's a
triple
orc thing
okay so i took the bishop
so the point is to now
the triple fork's not enough
i want to get quadruple forked
i willingly got quadruple forked
as maybe the title of the
the youtube video
it's really beautiful because the point
is
if uh if bishop d1 i i fork back
and if queen takes a1 i fork back
and in every situation i'll be up
material in the end
yeah so here i'm up a rook and a knight
a leeches tells me
but at least white has bond clouded
some
meme worthy commentation
[Music]
this was such a cool game
[Music]
like alekhine's g5 move
that opening tactic that almost
backfired
okay let's win
some more material
and then willingly getting
willingly getting quadruple forked
it's not something you see every day
let's still try and uh convert this
smoothly
this is kind of a funny move
i'm just trying to open the h file
not sure if i have a plan in mind after
pawn takes though
i guess the point is that after pawn
takes
then
like the king doesn't have the typical
getaway square so it might be easier to
meet
um yeah just play bishop d7
and now the bishop's pinned
the rooks tied down to defending the
bishop
the king has no legal moves
so the only things that can move are the
pawns
and yeah i'm ready to
win some more stuff
okay target the king
hmm
i like
oh i moved the rook
i was thinking i could castle wait i can
print wait
why can't i pre-move king g8
i move the rook right i move the rook
will leach us allow me to castle
no it doesn't
but allow me to pre-move king g8
wait
wait let's not blunder a rook
um let's take a pawn
okay i'm really curious if
it will allow the pre-move
because it shouldn't
you're not allowed to castle when you
moved one of your your things already
oh you can pre-move illegal moves it
just won't do it if it's illegal
but i can't pre-move like bishop
somewhere random
i guess maybe because
the king is on it can i pre-move this
now i can't pre-move king c8
okay so it didn't allow me to play king
g8
so not quite a a full bug
oh i can't castle with meat
there still might be some aesthetic mate
somewhere
and most of the squares around the king
are
taken or controlled
i'm trying to visualize a
eventual mate
maybe something with f6 e5
or maybe some rook lift
i guess like leachates would allow this
pre-move even though this would never be
possible by the king on e8
but it won't allow this pre-move
okay so i'm trying to lift the rook
ooh
[Music]
now this is the only legal move
oh that's also legal
i didn't see that move
okay let's play
king e7 getting opposition
i still have to control the square
so the potential made is like this and
then this this
or
this
no
let's start with this
if g5 is made in one
the goal is to mate before white flags
okay mission accomplished
okay thanks for the game
that was a fun one
like insane g5 move
and then
yeah queen d4 i thought it was going to
be like an easier win
but then
yeah it's very clever to give away the
bishop and then get my queen stuck
i'm actually wondering
i guess i was considering this during
the game
but of knight e3
uh
like when a3 knight b5
oh wow
[Music]
if this
is a funny line knight takes eight my
knight can take back
still up material
yeah then got this weird moment
so i was actually uh
like when i was calculating this
position oh no your queen
i wanted to play rook a1 first
and then knight before
but i thought this would have been like
too obvious
given here here like white would
probably see that
so it's more tricky to play knight
before first
even though the engine doesn't like this
because like in castle
oh rook h4 best move
okay knight d4 was still playable
and love the streaming schedule
europe-friendly time
oh i love you too thank you
nan
oh nantan chatur
chatur means chess in indonesian i think
okay so that goes on youtube hello to
youtube
you can watch live on twitch
if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free
or you could just subscribe for free on
youtube